on va pas se mentir c'était un petit peu
triste voilà c'est pour ça tu as is it
et même à venir aussi
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui s'est passé on
avait un rendez vous tous les deux
aujourd'hui cet après-midi pour
complètement autre chose
on vous laisse voir ça soit autant
puisqu'on doit se voir et on avait monté
des friteries et des kebabs
ouais moi le kebab et donc et c'est vrai
que il ya eu un malentendu hier les gens
m'ont dit c'est bon texte vient dans
l'émission demain mais ils n'ont pas
compris qu'en fait qu'il venait me voir
avant et on s'en est parlé et tu m'as
dit oui c'est vrai comme tu m'as annoncé
je vais venir mais c'est vrai que tu
voulais pas je trouve que c'est pas
c'est pas le moment il ya mon remplaçant
qui a commencé aujourd'hui faut être
discret moi je suis discret sur ce qui
se passe ça on n'est pas des gens à
plaindre et mais c'est un accident de
travail voilà on est je pense qu'on
n'est pas des gens à plein des jeux pas
envie de me plaindre mais juste tu étais
triste aussi voilà comme quelqu'un voilà
ty pas envie oui c'est pas le moment
voilà presque pas le moment on est épaté
pas voie lactée pas laisser les gens
fait avoir leur réflexion etc
je sais on est des êtres humains avant
tout donc faussée il ya des moments il y
avait je pense que ce n'était pas le
moment mais ehpad ans lui a demandé je
viens pas là et pat était pas dans ce
délire voilà de violence verbale et
voilà non mais c'est vrai et puis il est
là est venu parce que par amitié pour
julien besoin j'en profite pour dire je
m'en suis terriblement voulue même si à
l'heure s'est passé aux téléspectateurs
c'est vrai que c'était dans votre
émission
donc je suis ainsi la télé que ça arrive
les gens applaudissent il est là c'est
aux mécontents s'en mêle ayez la scène
et y voit la scène esi tiens j'ai envie
de monter sur scène y monte sur scène il
raconte une première blague tout va bien
je dis les gens applaudissent conservé
jeudi
tu nous as rencontré une petite dernière
avant de partir il n'y pas de problème
on fait l'émission pis aller c'est le
moment de se quitter alors textone à une
autre huawei oui il remonte sur scène et
c'est là où ça se passe bon et quand
elles passent et on s'est tous regardés
avec les chroniqueurs parce qu'on a
senti que malheureusement à l'époque où
nous vivons ça n'allait pas passer votre
tout de suite je lui dis tu devrais
aller voir ton compte twitter dans la
seconde
à mon avis ça va bouger et voilà mais il
l'a pas fait il est tel en tant
qu'humoriste en plus ya longtemps que
l'animateur tex est ce que tu as dit que
tu as des projets qui vont arriver ce
que tu as eu des contacts avec d'autres
télés ou pas d'autres oui oui oui il ya
plein de choses mais encore une fois
c'est pas le lieu ni le moment
vrai plein de choses je ne suis pas
malheureux geste était surtout très
content d'être là ce soir et en plus en
face de moi y arsène caire des cadreurs
désamour que j'adore et c'est dans le
ciel se fait virer
sa cape elle voulait profiter de ce soir
je me suis dit c'est quand même
l'occasion de dire au revoir aux gens de
leur dire que c'est pas de mon fait que
je suis désolé de quitter cette émission
j'espère qu'on a que vous garderez que
les bons souvenirs de ses 17 années
voilà voilà
je sais normalement là j'avais prévu un
établissement hier c'était c'était la
dernière enfin à l'antenne et c'est vrai
que comme tu savais pas donc tu tapes à
dire au revoir aux téléspectateurs dont
on profite pour le faire ici mal en
direct est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui regardent touche pas à mon
poste qui regardaient les amours avec
toi en tout cas moi je voudrais dire je
suis très très contente de voir et que
je suis sûr et certain
comme je t'ai dit tout à l'heure tu un
talent immense et franchement quoi qu'il
arrive tu vas tu vas vite trouvé des
trucs parce que des animateurs comme toi
y en a très très peu trop gentil merci
molle dit vraiment oui c'est justement
ce que comme vous êtes un animateur un
peu remarquable est-ce qu'il ya déjà des
chaînes qui sont positionnées clos à
pékin de me poser la question non c'est
pas possible mais sans décoller mais
maintenant je ne vais pas poser la
question c'est y répondre aux biens non
vient un peu d'en parler alors
aujourd'hui mon max du génome agen
images du jour de tpm pettex te dis la
vérité
c'est normal c'est la première des
amours de bruno guillon
alors j'aurai juste dire un truc sur un
mec parce que moi j'ai un énorme coup de
coeur pour un mec et ça c'est olivier
minne week a refusé j'aimerais qu'on tue
raconte vraiment juste ça parce que
c'est passé qu'olivier pape olivier on
se connaît quand même très très bien
savez il en était quasiment à égalité il
ya 17 ans pour présenter l'émission
et puis finalement c'est moi qui a été
choisi au moment où la fia lui demandant
de me remplacer c'est un des premiers
qu'on a appelés pour venir faire le
casting et moi je l'avais un petit peu
au téléphone avec ce qui se passait et
je sentais qu'il n'était pas tout à fait
à l'aise et le matin du casting je
l'appelle j'sais pas pourquoi une
vitesse j'ai pas dormi de la nuit
j'ai mal vécu le fait qu'on me demande
d'être remplacés et j'ai dit non et j'ai
trouvé ça tellement chevaleresque ont
été imités mon ami lui dévissé comme on
l'a dit c'est un gentleman exceptionnel
ex aequo à l'annoncé bourançon lille a
des belles photos on va créer une belle
photo alors aujourd'hui c'était la
première de de bruyne audio est ce que
tu la regardes et tu dis la vérité n'ont
pas eu le temps ce matin tu bosse et
j'ai regardé c'est vrai j'ai jeté un
oeil oui j'ai jeté un oeil à thomas lors
où c'est l'image que vous allez nous
dire souvent pensé que tête je veux pas
ton avis parce que je veux pas que le
problème n'est rien du tout donc voilà
mais on sait y va du jour regarde il a
tenu d'ailleurs à commencer son émission
en dédiant les applaudissements à textes
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur le plateau d amour un public en
pleine forme merci pour vos artistes
les applaudissements que je veux dédier
ce matin à mon camarade texte c'est que
j'embrasse alors là c'est que c'est
plutôt fair-play voisins